hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday November 11th 2019 oh do I
sound happy do I do I sound a little
joyful two nights ago actually your LSU
Tigers went into Tosca loose cotton with
all those shark tooth fedora where and
so-and-so's huh the last state in the
Union to let black people go into a
7-eleven and get a Slurpee I don't know
if that's true
LSU Tigers go in and beat the Alabama
Crimson Tide oh my god how nervous was
Nick Saban's wife at the end of that
[ __ ] gave now kids just you know try
not to look at him when he comes home
you know how he gets
I got to take something about Nick Saban
I think that there there was some sort
of weakness there I can't figure it out
but it has to do something with his hair
dye okay now obviously when you look at
how bad his dye job is what you're
really seeing on the surface is an
extremely focused individual okay the
man does not have time to go to the
beauty pie
and get his hair did he just doesn't
he's too focused on winning yet another
yet another goddamn championship you
know and he's gonna he's going to go
down in history
once it enough time goes by being bigger
than Bear Bryant that's right
gradually over that's the decades you
will see less houndstooth fedoras and
you're gonna see more hair plugged wigs
with like skull bandage you [ __ ] comb
through it whatever the [ __ ] it is okay
you do see focus in his dye job but what
I also
is I see an inherently vain man and
withal vain man that there's a [ __ ]
somewhere in that [ __ ] armor okay oh
wait can I not be on SNL now it's an
expression there's somewhere in there
the fact that this man that this [ __ ]
man has to take the time to dye his hair
there's something going on there there's
an insecurity there's a fear of Aging
there's something going on there that
that can be exploited and I don't know
what it is and I think LSU came in there
all right with their head football coach
who came out with the [ __ ] number one
fingers in the air when he came out the
tunnel the audacity the bravado the
machismo came running out of that
[ __ ] tunnel and of course he did
he's got a full head of beautiful hair
he sounds like a Cajun Hulk Hogan and
what I think happened in the middle of
that game was Nick Saban second-guessed
himself because when he looked across
the field he saw too much man standing
across from him and your LSU Tigers came
in put forty-six wonderful points up on
the Crimson Tide and they rolled tide
rolled right back to the locker room
with their first loss of the year
tumbling from number two in the country
all the way down to number four and
still being in the playoff how does that
happen I don't know I don't know I'm
gonna say chickie because people hate
him so much it's just great for the
ratings I'm actually helping Alabama
stay in the playoff with how much over
the years rooting for LSU I suddenly
hate Alabama which I never did I don't
really hate them it's just fun to root
against them alright well look at this
[ __ ] I don't understand they've played
one ranked team this year and they just
got their butts
by like what three points it let up 46
up let's let's look at Alabama's let's
look at their schedule this is who the
[ __ ] they played okay going back to
where the hell are we where are we where
are we all right
they started off with Duke I'm not
[ __ ] on [ __ ] Duke I mean they can
play basketball you take off the pads
you put on some short shorts and that
those guys are a problem okay you put
the pads on you go outside all of a
sudden they they look like Ivy League
players they played Duke oh yeah you
think that's scares you and then they
played I think New Mexico State and M
State I'm gonna guess New Mexico State
then they played South Carolina who in
years have been good they're not ranked
this year then they played Southern
Mississippi then they played Mississippi
none of these teams are ranked then they
played Texas A&M who have been good at
types not ranked but as this Alabama's
fault they're beaten the [ __ ] out of
them I don't know how this works then
they played Tennessee who always start
always go bigger Goldberger Nashville
nothing and they played Arkansas it's
really not their fault that all these
programs are in the in the [ __ ] right
now I have to I mean I don't hate
Alabama enough to [ __ ] ignore that
fact but then the one team that they
play yeah they lost 46 to 41 a home game
in the last one what a [ __ ] garbage
goddamn touchdown that was [ __ ] LSU
Jesus Christ 46 you know would that be
34 little more impressive but whatever
all right but then as much as I'm
bitching about them let's go to look at
the Ohio State's [ __ ] schedule the
Ohio State you ever seen somebody so
proud of a state school it's like you
ever go to Ohio half the people you met
graduated from Ohio State Ohio State is
to school that people from Ohio go to
when they can't get accepted to a real
school in another state
why am I doing this I have roadwork next
year all right ohio state buckeyes right
the big fat [ __ ] Midwestern people
waddle and their pasty asses into that
[ __ ] horseshoe which is no longer a
horseshoe they started off with mighty
Florida Atlantic then they played 17th
ranked Cincinnati so already there ahead
of Alabama then they played the
perennial powerhouse 24th ranked Indiana
and I don't know what these teams were
ranked when they played him in defense
of [ __ ] Ohio State then they played
Miami of Ohio right that's a little nod
to global warming Miami is now in Ohio
right because the oceans have risen then
they played Nebraska whose just been I
don't know what they've been doing for
the last [ __ ] 20 years then they
played Michigan State then they played
Northwestern then they played Wisconsin
then they played Maryland next week they
play Rutgers i mean jesus [ __ ] christ
all right then who's else is in the top
we got Clemson I mean how do you tell
who's number one when these [ __ ] you got
like three powerhouse teams that are
just all in [ __ ] [ __ ] divisions
Clemson played [ __ ] in this camp is that
a misprint Citadel its last year right
ok they played Georgia Tech Texas A&M
Syracuse Charlotte UNC Florida State
Louisville Boston College Wolford is
that a woman's School of Nursing I
didn't know what the [ __ ] that is and
then they played NC State so the only
way I feel that you can really judge
anybody at this point is Alabama's loss
to LSU because neither Ohio State or
Clemson has played anybody nearly ranked
that high I don't know they only lost by
[ __ ] 5 who cares but you know
something at least they got a goddamn
playoff all I know is that the LSU
Tigers you got to take that Alabama you
can try and shake that off with your
stupid I hate you know what I can't
stand about Alabama fans
many of them go actually go wear Blazers
to the goddamn [ __ ] game you know
what I mean like they're actually
intelligent you know what I mean walk in
there with their khakis and their
[ __ ] loafers like those [ __ ] TCU
people I saw at the Rose Bowl all year I
idaite that [ __ ] thing there is
actually I will say though you know with
all the attacks on white privilege it is
nice to see some people that are still
proud of their white privilege I I do
there is something I find it funny on
one level I was just like I wish all of
these people would walk into the most
feminist [ __ ] school ever and come in
and have no idea about any of their new
theories on how we should live in a
society all right I'm almost out of
breath here I was so [ __ ] excited I
watched the game in Boston and then I
went over to do the the comics come home
Denis Leary 25th anniversary Denis Leary
cam neely amazing night Pete Holmes
Joey Annette e Kelly McFarland Bobby
Kelly John Mulaney I know I'm gonna
forget somebody I did say Lenny Clark
right who was an amazing amazing amazing
amazing show had such a great time
Eugene Mirman came down to hang out was
great to see him it was just awesome
it's that's what I love about that gig
is not only the people that you work
with there's always a couple couple of
people that come down and hang out so it
was really cool anyway so I went there
to [ __ ] watch you know of course this
like [ __ ] a quarter left and I have
to go run over to go do this show so I
go in there and I'm like [ __ ] there's
got to be a TV there's got to be a TV in
here right we're in the [ __ ] Boston
Garden there's got to be a TV and I walk
into where the whole crews eating and
there are eight glorious flat-screen TVs
in this kitchen area and they all have
on the USC like Arizona State game or
whatever Jesus Christ
I don't know who the [ __ ] is a fan of
[ __ ] USC is beyond me somebody said
to me one time he said you know
something they have the most corrupt
football program historically in college
football and I kind of got a go at that
where it's just like any time if there's
a scandal that involves more than one
school they're always gonna be that
other school they have had some very
scoundrel ish behavior over there so I'm
like guys can we please put on the LSU
Alabama game right it's a pro football
town nobody seems to give a [ __ ] it took
like 15 minutes before they finally got
it on my buddies were sending me videos
of all the [ __ ] scores I was
convinced that Alabama was gonna come
back and beat him because they always
seemed to do that and then they turned
the TV right as alabama scored that go
ahead touchdown with their running back
I don't know their [ __ ] names that
kid at 22 I think he had a great goddamn
game look reminded me of Joe Morris back
in the day on the New York Giants and I
just lost my [ __ ] I just went that's
right you [ __ ] lose that was the only
person flip it out nobody else cared and
I look like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and I was celebrating and I was talking
all of this [ __ ] like I had something to
do with it like I've been a lifelong fan
rather than just being a fan since 2007
when I moved out to Los Angeles and as I
said that for whatever [ __ ] reason
LSU's playing like I guess tight
coverage or something they let this guy
in Alabama get behind him and they
immediately score a touchdown I was just
like you got to be [ __ ] kidding me
are they really gonna do this
so anyways congratulations to LSU oh and
i watched right before that i watched
the last half of the minnesota Penn
State game you know and I was rooting
for Penn State because Ohio State fans
always [ __ ] moan and complain about
Alabama being in the playoff and then
not being in the playoff despite the
fact when they finally get in there they
got their [ __ ] asses kicked right and
always say the SCC's weaker than the big
ten I'm gonna start a lot of [ __ ] I'm
gonna get a lot of emails here okay and
then there was just one [ __ ] year
both Penn State and Ohio State both had
a loss okay and [ __ ] Ohio State's
loss was to Penn State and they still
got the nod to go to the [ __ ] playoff
and they stand they still have the nerve
to [ __ ] moan and complain every [ __ ]
year so just cuz are their [ __ ]
whining I for some reason like root
against them now I can't totally root
against them because my buddy law had
such a huge fan so I'm always like happy
for him if something good happens for
them but that was good for them that
Penn State just lost so now they're the
only undefeated guys in the the East I
guess you'd call it and everybody's
trying to say hey Minnesota is for real
they're not for real I'm sorry they're
not okay there they are like doing well
for Minnesota they are undefeated oh
Jesus it comes to [ __ ] very polite
angry letters from Minnesota come on
dude yeah we all know [ __ ] they would
get [ __ ] smoked by an SEC team SEC is
still where it's at
I still think Alabama beats Minnesota I
still think that they LSU could beat
Minnesota
I still think both of those teams could
[ __ ] beat anybody else in the Big Ten
Ohio State I don't know we'll see we
shall see but what would be [ __ ] great
is what if LSU plays Ohio State in the
college football championship game and
the recruit that they wouldn't let start
who's now gone down to LSU you know I
love all Alabama was giving him [ __ ]
saying you're [ __ ] your free agent
that you got it's like what you could
have got him Alabama God knows you
[ __ ] sign everybody else you [ __ ]
greedy [ __ ] it is ridiculous how much
I'm into college football this year I
don't understand it it's phenomenal rom
so congratulations to the LSU Tigers
here's the deal I actually I'm going to
read a little bitty advertising here and
then after that I have a special guest
that I'm bringing onto the podcast but I
wanted to do this person justice but so
I had I had to get the LSU [ __ ] out of
my [ __ ] system
I got it out oh my god I mean it was
worth losing to him the last [ __ ]
seven years just to see that [ __ ] him
in [ __ ] Tuscaloosa and they're all
[ __ ] making excuses now who actually
knew you me with your [ __ ]
houndstooth [ __ ] PJs you've been
crying in all night
alright let's read a little advertising
oh look who's here honey
giving holiday gifts is great
overspending on all those gifts is
definitely not so why spend more than
you have to finding the lowest price is
easy if you have honey honey is a free
browser extension that automatically
finds the best promo codes when whenever
you shop online this means you always
get the best deals without ever trying
on over 20,000 sites what this means you
always get the best deal without even
trying on over 20,000 sites such as what
is trying on me Amazon eBay j-cruise
Sephora Expedia Target Best Buy and more
honey has found it's over 10 million
members over a billion dollars in
savings 10 million members that's like
100 bucks each honey
supports over 200,000 stores online
honey has over a hundred thousand five
star reviews on google chrome's google
chrome store if you're buying gifts this
holiday season
then you need honey if you're not you
probably know someone who is so do don't
do them a solid and tell them about
honey honey can help make sure that
you're getting the best price for
whatever you're buying it's free to use
and installs in just two clicks get for
free at join honey dot-com / / that's
join honey dot-com / / oh look who's
here everybody our good friends all zip
hiring can be a slow process Caffrey
Alturas CEO Oh Dylan misko it's
my favorite name of all time Dylan Miska
whit's uh faded back to Paris he had
some over the millage disco at twenty
that's the five needed to hire a
director of coffee for his organic
coffee company but he was having trouble
finding qualified applicants so he
switched to zip zip recruiter doesn't
depend on candidates finding you it
finds them for you it's technology
identifies people with the right
experience and invites them to apply to
your job you get qualified candidates
fast
Dylan poss posted his job on zip
recruiter and said he was so impressed
by how quickly he had a great he had
great candidates apply he also use it
candidates rating feature to filter his
applicants so he could focus on the most
relevant once and that's how Dylan Miska
wits Dylan misc awaits that's how Ellen
found his new director of coffee in just
a few days director of coffee as a great
job to bring up at a high school reunion
what do you do oh I just got hired by
Dylan Miska wits to be director of
coffee oh yeah you're working it's a box
with results like that it's no wonder
I'm in charge of putting all the filters
and all the machines with results like
that it's no wonder four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate within the first day
see why zip is effective for businesses
of all sizes try zip recruiter for free
at our website zip recruited comm slash
bird that zip recruited comm / / zip
dot-com the smartest way to hire zi p r
e CR u ITER comm / burn oh look who's
look who's last huh
to me on these me undies getting ready
for the holidays doo doo doo doo me
undies me under your [ __ ] heads in a
haze why are we buying all this [ __ ]
[ __ ] the planets going to hell show me
your tits you can't say that but you can
keep buying [ __ ] there's no more fish
left but still get sushi alright me
undies it's officially the holidays and
people are shopping for gifts I'm
actually you know something I really
think that people should go out and if
somebody already has their Christmas
lights on before Thanksgiving okay I'm
gonna see some feminists that say that
this is turkey shaming and they go out
and they short-circuit all of those
lights and they don't let them to come
on until african-american Friday see how
progressive I am right after
Thanksgiving all right it's officially
the holidays and people are already
shopping for gifts before you freak out
man about what to get your boyfriend who
you've only been dating for four months
or what to get your mailman is that a
thing or the fact that you have to go to
gasp the mall listen up the undies is
anything but ordinary do you buy your
boyfriend of four months underwear you
got to ask yourself that question
especially you know if you haven't
banged yet let's say you're you know
you're not into that you're taking it
slow if you give them the underwear then
you got to make sure you don't give them
the bananahammock ones because then he's
gonna be thinking like all right it's on
right just hear those sleigh bells ring
a ling here's my [ __ ] thing uh sir
money is anything but ordinary they have
a gift for literally everyone yes
including your weird aunt and the best
pup she's weird you're the one buying
her underwear she's the victim in this
story okay and the best part is they
delivered straight to your door with
free shipping that's a holiday miracle
right there speaking of not wanting to
leave the house the undies makes the
perfect hibernation undies and
loungewear whether you're looking to
mash undies with your boo this cuffing
season or just wanting to cuddle up with
your favorite furry fur
and in a onesie me undies has you
covered literally I might get my wife a
onesie there fabric is three times
softer than cotton and offered an X
sizes extra small hey me undies I don't
want any [ __ ] onesies by the way all
right I have enough [ __ ] ok 4 XL 3x
softer than cotton is like being 3/8
three times so all three at three times
softer than those cute little
marshmallows at the top of your hot coco
different prints colors styles me undies
nose it's friggin cold out which is why
they're coming out with even more cuddly
products this holiday season cozy up
with their robes for men and women treat
yourself in their in their soft new
slippers and of course match the whole
family
with their soft new baby bodysuit my god
these [ __ ] covering the whole thing
they do everything but me undies does
everything but come over to your house
and light the fire in the fireplace
before anybody's gonna be like what burn
your house down
what kind of read was it alright me
undies has no wicked sorry number two
with brave with brand new holiday prints
come on bill and cozy new products me
undies has your gift for literally any
everyone me undies has a great offer
from my listeners for any first-time
purchasers you can get 15% off and free
shipping this is a no-brainer especially
because they have a hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee to get your first
15% off to get your 15% off your first
pair of free shipping one percent
satisfaction guarantee go to me undies
calm / bird that's meu and di es calm /
/
alright slow us slow show announcement
I'm gonna be performing at the Mahalia
Jackson remember that commercial a long
time ago
mahalia jackson the queen of gospel or
something like that Mahalia Jackson
theater of the Performing Arts in New
Orleans On January 9th and 10th gee why
would I be down there on that weekend
wink-wink nudge-nudge presale two's
November 12th the same day the
Mandalorian comes out I'm in Star Wars
all of these years are making fun of it
now I'm in it and now I'm promoting it
you see see what the business did they
suck you in and then they silence you
comes out tomorrow the Mandalorian this
is the Star Wars if you like me you
always wanted to see all right you can
tell by the trailer no Ewoks baby I
don't even know if that's true don't
listen to me I don't know what you know
I just know what he walks are because
I've heard enough people complain about
him all right presale is Tuesday
November 12th at 10:00 a.m. the CST code
oh sorry 10 a.m. Central Standard Time
that's CST was something I was trying to
figure out what that was ah God
promoting tickets while while not
selling them all at the same time that's
what I'm doing here right now I'd like
to go but he sounds too stupid do I want
to listen to that for an hour
all right the code is birbee you are our
presale Tuesday November 12th at 10 a.m.
Central Standard Time it's on sale to
the public Friday November 15th at 10:00
a.m. Central Standard Time link will be
shared on social or go to Ticketmaster
and search BRR
all right that is the big deal and I'll
tell you right now I'm gonna leave a
pair of [ __ ] tickets for the Cajun
Hulk Hogan you know but I know he's not
gonna use them because it's gonna be too
busy preparing for the national
championship game right now you guys
don't believe me well I'm gonna do it
edie order on my Sandy's name right okay
all right with that I'm gonna take a
pause here it's not gonna be a pause for
you guys cause it's just gonna click
right back on while I wait for my guests
to show up here and I'm gonna go eat a
sad salad because I got to get I got to
get back on it I got to get back on it
old Twinkle Toes I got to stay in
[ __ ] showbiz shape that's what it is
you know you don't think there's body
shaming for a toxic white male well
there is ladies okay
so why don't you go trim your clams and
have a little empathy for once in your
[ __ ] life all right when I come back
I have a guest bah bah bah bah stop all
right and just like that I am back and
as promised I have a very special guest
one of my favorite comics on this on the
on the circuit is that what they call it
now out there on the circuit the
absolutely amazing Jessica Kirsten who
has a new stand-up special done with all
things comedy that wonderful company
called talking to myself that comes out
December 6th on Comedy Central Jessica
how are you well I have a special coming
out because of you know you don't you
have a special coming out because I'm
sick of going on after you having to get
my head together to figure out what I'm
gonna talk about so I'm hoping you blow
up on this and you get the [ __ ] out of
the clubs so I can go down there and
relax oh my god if anyone can follow me
it's you I got lost and this is widely
said it's like you need you need a game
plan to go on after you you do yeah you
know I wanna see you don't like take a
night off you just go up there you're
like the well she's gonna hit a lot of
double plays but she's gonna hit good 48
home runs ever you swing out of your
cleats I'll tell you what happened I
used to take it down before other comics
so that they would feel better and not
have to work hard and then I was like
what the [ __ ] am i doing right you know
people please well there's always always
always why did it take so long for you
know why were all these other comics god
bless them getting specials before you I
because you were being nice yeah maybe
that's part of it but I really feel
ready now I don't know if I would have a
while ago like I just feel so ready for
it
ya know I think you're gonna blow up in
I don't really I'm hoping that's
happening because I'm a huge fan and
then also you're gonna make our company
look good I know you where's it where do
you find these nuggets these where do
you find these people it's like well
they're right [ __ ] there you guys
just don't seem to look you know what I
have to tell you this should make you
happy
I have had so many comics say to me I
gotta turn this chair cuz my neck is
[ __ ] up cuz I what's wrong with it
I try to make my daughter laugh and she
right now she's loving the double take
and at 51 doing the double take as much
as I love to hear her laugh is really
[ __ ] my neck up so I got to make sure
that I'm just that is so sad that that's
how you were I mean it's a beautiful
thing but it's really I'd love to tell
you I fell off a motorcycle or I know
something exciting know where I was
benching yeah that's how [ __ ] up my
shoulders you know my buddy my buddy
just turned 40 or 41 today and he's
doing a classic thing that I did when I
started get old and you start [ __ ]
freaking out and he was just going like
dude I'm gonna get in like the sickest
shape and he goes I'm gonna try to run a
five something 40-yard dash right and
it's like I told him I was good don't do
that dude you need to you need to come
up with a workout for your age because
that's well that's how I [ __ ] up my
shoulders was I got back into the gym
and the big thing when I was a kid was
was 225 putting up to 25 because you had
to [ __ ] forty-fives on each side of
the bar and it looked cool so I was like
I'm gonna get back to that and I had
already [ __ ] my shoulder up and didn't
realize it so I started off with just
like I was literally like 130 540 pounds
in the first three times I brought it
down I felt this burning in my oh right
shoulder so I'm from the eighth he's no
pain no gain I kept going through it and
my shoulders been [ __ ] up since I
finally rehabbed the right one and now
my left one you know I mean I should
have rehabbed it a long time ago but it
it involves like rotator cuffs involve
incredible patience I know I know when
we've gone through I don't have I know I
don't either most people just say [ __ ]
it they only like an operation or
something it's like what most people do
yeah I'm going to go get physical that I
just it's a lot oh yeah they always take
out these little balls
yeah I hate me feel I'm very
uncomfortable I have to tell you when
they're like okay one two like I feel
like someone should make sure I know
that sounds weird you have lumbar
support yeah who even knows what lumbar
is I guess it's a back thing
but let me tell you this before I forget
because it's very important all right so
many comics from LA and New York have
said to me that what you did for me gave
them so much hope I told Mike Maronna
that it's money well that's just me
constantly not you I'm just a brave face
of that company yeah you are you're the
most handsome orange face yeah of that
you know it's funny I actually took a
meeting recently and I was pitching you
know what we're doing you know dump
they're doing my little song and dance
in LA as you do and I was trying to
describe our company and this woman goes
I swear to god she goes oh so you just
find like a bunch of weirdos and you
kind of weirdo yeah and then she kind of
caught herself she goes well not weirdos
I go is that what you call like the
funny people the way that you passed
over
that's unbelievable no it is that's so
typical of who makes decisions in
Hollywood to Qualcomm she was cool and
everything but I just was like that's
sort of been a running joke with me and
the other guy were in the meeting it
says asked what we do we just find these
weirdos you know those people that
actually have an hour of material have
actually done all the rooms in our
seasoned and already yeah to do
something so I just thought it was I
kind of made me at first I was taken
aback like wow man I can't believe she
just said that but then afterwards I
took it as a compliment of being like
alright well I think I'm doing something
I think I think we're doing something
right here you are well we had well we
had virzi and then we had Edwards and
they both smashed it and then now we got
you coming out and what I love is all we
did was just try to find the funniest
people our most favorite people that for
whatever reason hadn't gotten a special
yet and then we were like accidentally
progressive looking I know I know I mean
you really with me you got pretty it's
good yeah yeah that's how progressive I
am by the way by the way I [ __ ] went
up last night here in New York oh my god
where I did the stand and then I did New
York Comedy Club in
I'm doing those places because I find
when I come back here if I go to the old
places like I don't know what about New
York and Boston it's the same way I go
there because I started there so long
ago because some of my friends are just
not there anymore either literally have
passed on with the business or just
don't do stand-up anymore
you go in you know and you just you
can't help but look for a familiar face
and they're not there it just makes me
depressed so I wasn't gonna go down to
the club's that I always go to so I you
know the stand is new New York Comedy
Club is new right so I went down there
and I went downstairs and there was a
woman on stage and I could just hear the
way the crowd was laughing I was like
what's going on with this show
and they go oh they said something was
built around a podcast oh yeah like
there was a woman who had a podcast and
it was her show I say all right forget
it I'm not going on this one so it's a
specific audience I'm gonna bomb yeah
and then I went upstairs
isn't it amazing you say that yeah I'm
not a bomb I already such a comic I love
that yeah I'm not gonna interrupt I'm
ruined their [ __ ] night and I'm not
gonna get unless people don't care yeah
I'm not doing that so then I go upstairs
and they have like the the in a little
lunch hall there in the back of the club
I go could I go up here I did that the
other night I enjoyed Arirang it's
amazing yeah my podcast what's that one
was like the Indian comedian showcase
and it's like all right so now what I'm
gonna be the toxic white male who comes
on this show and I'm like [ __ ] and I was
gonna I was gonna literally lead the
club but the guys running the shows like
no no no go on go on go on
and I went up and I had a I had like an
okay set like it's the weirdest yeah
thing we're part of getting old I think
is this is what happens but the weird
thing about this generation is it's
usually like the young people are
shocking you yeah now I'm finding it's
like they're boring me to tears it's
interesting isn't it no it's it's I mean
it's upsetting I wanted to be like show
me then what's around the corner what's
next yeah make me feel like I know I'm
slowing down and they're up there you
know the crowd just makes you feel like
I don't I walk out of there going like I
may have
[ __ ] [ __ ] like I I feel like stupid
when I do stand up here now it's not
like that around the country but it's a
really like a weird thing with like LA
in New York there is there's something
about people who move here they just
think they're so amazing that simply
that they moved here and then they think
all of their thoughts are the be-all
end-all of the direction of society
should go in and then they're like I
don't know like and it wasn't like
hostile fear well it wasn't like hostile
yeah yeah I feel like they kind of grew
up with these [ __ ] phones and [ __ ] so
they kind of used to being watched so
they have like it's like Al Gore energy
where you just kind of like Monica was
just like so outside his body yeah that
whole time he ran for president they're
not present is that what they're not
present and they're overthinking
everything that's the difference too
like I feel like people used to just sit
and really just be in the comedy show
and listen and me I feel like they're
overthinking things like their thinking
about what you said it's like no just be
there and just have fun and let go
yeah I'm saying something stupid here
right if you think about I laugh every
time when I'm making some dumb face or
doing like a character and they're just
staring at me trying to figure me out
I'm like you're never gonna figure me
out
there's your net it's not like I'm an
idiot
there's no there's no layers here yeah
nothing there's nothing a [ __ ] idiot
right now how long ago did uh first of
all would you start here in New York
and I busted my I mean I'm talking open
mics for years I was like from the
Boston comedy club you know age and I
started in 99 so 20 years there you go
and uh and I just worked hard from the
beginning I loved it I don't I love it
now I don't love it as much as I used to
because of how everyone is so crazy why
I do stand-up here it so it's a little
or if you do stand-up in LA it's a
little like I don't know what I don't
know what it is like the whole thing
I don't something happen I see something
up I go in Trump one right yeah and then
SNL had that actor on there dressed as
Hillary Clinton playing the piano
singing like kumbaya I was just like
what the [ __ ] happened
like this show they used to be like they
were like anarchists I know they weren't
aligned with the political party and I'm
not just not singling out that show but
that show is such like a like a
juggernaut that and it was just like
wait a minute so are they trying to
suggest that like Hillary Clinton's like
a decent human being I mean none of
these people are yeah and like that was
I felt like that was the angle of that
show back in the day where it would sort
of make fun of everybody but it's sort
of like I felt that they were saying hey
we all voted for Hillary in Hillary's a
saint
almost religiously like by playing this
religious song hmm
III mean maybe I missed the point of it
but when I watched that I was just like
what of really most people are in the
middle on so many I mean I even am like
if people look at me I'm a woman I'm a
little older I'm married to a woman like
they think I think a certain way and I
don't I think that's why so many guys
start following me once they see my act
or hear me on a podcast they're like oh
she doesn't think like I'm not overly
liberal no you know it's right if I if
I'm in [ __ ] New York people think I
voted for Trump and if I go to like
Nebraska they think I voted for Hillary
I'm like I didn't vote for either one of
those [ __ ] it whatever it's just I
don't know I always get on this [ __ ]
stupid subject I feel like I'm feeding
it so I should I should stop but um so
this this latest hour tell us about your
latest hour stayed up like how did you
like throughout all of those years when
you should have got a special and you
didn't right what would you do with all
of that like how did you handle that
material well I did a bunch of like TV
spots where I did some of the material a
lot of it but I yeah I mean that was
some well I don't compare myself and get
better thank God I don't go there I'm
not like she got this and that person
but did you ever well I mean the only
thing I did really was with specials I
was like what the [ __ ] is going on this
is crazy I should get a special this is
like yeah yeah I'm trying to get on
Letterman yeah see somebody else get it
that [ __ ] guy got out of you know I
think they made so many mistakes with
all of those shows that now they're
going back to really trying a little bit
to get people who are funny do you know
you're white and whatever I think
there's a zillion people and I really
don't think it's personal I think it's
[ __ ] chaos it's not personal
yeah and everybody is just doing the
best they can and there's no [ __ ] way
the people in the industry can figure
out who all the good people are because
they're too busy doing that [ __ ]
office thing trying not to get rich
exactly they're trying to cast stuff too
like they have to fill in I mean I I
know cuz I've worked behind the scenes
do like you have and I started producing
a lot of stuff and I see what happens
I see no I've learned that now yet we're
trying to develop stuff yes like
certainly be develop you like all this
person is easy and then the other the
best people to try to develop stuff with
whether they understand yeah and there's
sort of patience but when you get with
somebody it's just like I don't [ __ ]
under this it's six minutes later and I
don't have it and I want to know what
the [ __ ] is going on you know like holy
[ __ ] oh this is the other side of the
table yeah totally and I I'm also happy
that it I believe it or not I'm happy it
has not been easy for me I know that
sounds crazy that I'm saying that
because I've been through so much in
this business but I'm happy like no one
did hand anything oh yeah because now
it's built in bedrock yeah I mean I do
all of those [ __ ] rooms now when you
go up in front of a gay crowd do you do
you find that they automatically like
you or they then love I mean they love
you love me lesbians sometimes I could
they get offended sometimes and I get
enraged because they're my people so it
just makes my own ass suck dick I'm like
please make me straight please God do
something after this show it's very hard
for me it's with Jewish people to older
Jews when they get hostile and offended
and mad and I'm like please you're my
people like just let go
do you but or that on all fairness when
you go up do you try to [ __ ] with them a
little bit yeah I Jason do you feel cuz
you feel like they feel like oh you
don't you are what I am there for you
think the way I do do you deliberately
go up there and maybe
throw a couple now I do but for a of
course for a while when I had no money
and I was desperate I had to just play
the game because I wanted to get paid do
you have any good stories of lesbian
crowds not liking you
oh I've there are a lot of times someone
will come up to me I was very offended
when you said the thing about
disabilities because I have a disability
and I have a dog and now I'm really rude
back but before I'd be like I'm so sorry
I'll never say that and I wouldn't say
the joke again like I would get feel
really bad because I'm really empathetic
I was gonna say yeah you're like try it
now I'm like [ __ ] you I'm I when people
try to silence me it enrages me
especially women like when another woman
tries to silence me I'm like you're not
supposed to do that like let me be free
to say you know what that is that's
that's the fallout of all those years of
you being overly empathetic to people
who were not showing you any empathy I
know and then you got to work out why
did I do that
to begin with I know why I did it why I
mean I just like because I would put
other people's needs before myself and
why because I wanted them to like me
why I'll tell you exactly why cuz my
mother's a therapist and she brought me
up because you're gonna laugh it's
really true
anytime something happened with someone
I was my fault and I had a look at what
I did to make it happen she [ __ ] me up
that way I'm serious I mean she meant
well but like you know our teacher once
threw a brush at me or something and I
told her like well what did you do to
make that happen why did he throw that
at you what did you do to it so I've
never signed myself his building rage no
no no no I'm saying that's what she
would say oh right right you don't know
what he's gone through and he's had a
hard time so it was I literally my
entire life was brought up like that
yeah I my thing I used to be the way you
were I know and my thing was everyone
was [ __ ] with me my whole life yeah
you know I had [ __ ] orange hair I
just there was nowhere to hide I used to
get my act I hated punk rockers you know
when they would dye their hair and they
thought they were rebels it's like dude
you can wash that out like this is the
[ __ ]
life sentence you know yeah I can just
take the staples out of your face
go back to your brunette hair and just
slip back into the matrix anytime you've
had enough yet so yeah I just found that
if I just I don't even know I was doing
it I used to just adjust my personality
to everyone around me yeah so I would
just sit like a [ __ ] glove and then
everybody [ __ ] liked me and then
meanwhile I wasn't speaking up for
myself I wasn't sticking up for myself
and then all the friends that I had a
lot not all of them but a lot of them
were like oh this part I'm Frank this
person likes me because I do whatever
they want to do so it wasn't like a real
find you those people find people like
that I see they're like child molesters
they go to a park and they can see the
kids they can you know manipulate yeah
there are a lot of people who can find
people like the way well because what it
is it's it's you're the only they're
such [ __ ] yeah the more empathetic
you are if you don't if you wield it
just with you know there's no Governor
on it yeah is your chances of meeting an
absolute the biggest [ __ ] ever are
exponential because that you are
literally the only person that will
tolerate it [ __ ] exactly right right
so I saw a lot of that growing up and
then I did it and then somewhere in my
late 20s I became one of the angriest
men on the earth I feel and I'm like
seriously well I walk for the first like
25 years of my life I thought I was kind
of this happy-go-lucky and everybody
else did yeah what happened was is you
spend a third of a century doing what
other people want you to do you end up
in a place you don't want to be and I
and I found like I was ended up I mean I
did start stand-up at twenty-three
almost 24 and the stand-up thing I think
because I was so I had such social
anxiety I was just like I'll just become
a comedian people will see that I'm
funny they'll like me and then everyone
will stop [ __ ] with me like I
literally did it as like an
advertisement this is Bill he's silly he
smiles and he works totally clean he
doesn't offend anybody and now let's all
just you know go in and when I got
offstage I had known
for everybody to come up to me what it
was was I just knew that everybody now
thought I was funny and I was cool then
I could now relax in the room and sit by
myself in the corner so I was doing that
and if you're like that personality you
know you're not gonna get the girl or
whatever the [ __ ] you're into you're not
gonna get the job you're not gonna get
the gig you're not gonna get because
everybody else is being like no I want
that I want that and then you [ __ ]
start resenting those people for
speaking up for themselves and then just
spelling all of this energy resenting
all of these people simply because
they're asking for what they [ __ ]
want and then you've also attracted all
these super [ __ ] toxic people yeah
yeah so that means the exact same thing
right and and then also a halfway
through that then you realize what an
[ __ ] you are and then all the
[ __ ] that you're doing because then
you go through the whole other thing of
like oh that's what I'm doing oh my god
I'm a victim I'm just this nothing and
then you get to that level off point
like then the overcorrect and then you
got to come back to be like okay I'm
also a [ __ ] and I'm moody yeah I'm
opinionated I interrupt fish yeah oh I
know so
III at a certain point thought I'm being
a complete victim I don't have patience
for that anymore with people I think
there's a certain point you can milk it
and then [ __ ] move on well you can't
because you're not gonna get what you
want because nobody gives a [ __ ] I know
yeah
people will pretend oh it's really hard
for you can I ask you as a woman
comedian do you feel it's harder for you
guys to take the mic out of the mic
stand than a male comic no I don't feel
like it's harder for me I actually feel
like did you even hear what I just said
oh literally have [ __ ] with you
you're so self-involved I literally go
is it harder for you guys to take a mic
out of a mic stand you just answered
that I was like wow this is great how
she's doing this I hate myself that I
was like yeah it is yeah no oh God so
that wasn't a real question yeah that
was very funny I wish I'd caught on
right away I do the same thing no I just
find it funny like the all of that it's
harder for me it's harder this this is
harder it's
just like I always look I'll sign off on
its harder but I I don't sign on did you
have it easy this everybody it's hard
the whole [ __ ] thing is hard there's
some people who have it more hard that's
it well this is an interesting because I
did it I was on stage with Nikki Glaser
and Rachel Feinstein
the other night and this woman we did a
question/answer I think was hysterical
and this woman in this black woman in
the back said what do you think about it
being very hard for black comedian
female comedians that they don't get
booked a lot it's very hard for them and
I said listen I'm in my late forties I'm
heavy I'm gay it has been very hard for
me to like there it's it's hard for a
lot of like I can get black backlash for
this but right now at this very moment
it's hard for white guys who are
starting out like that's shocking for
people to hear me say but that's it's
just it's hard for different people at
different times and I it's just it's the
pendulum swing spending goes all the way
over there I think it's gonna kind of
let it's like to be anything the me to
think no one was listening to women and
guys are doing all this horrible [ __ ]
and then the cork finally blows off the
bottle and then it way [ __ ]
overcorrection every guy gets treated
like he took his dick out at work or
knew somebody who did and helped cover
it up and now it's it's it's coming back
now like I just saw something recently
like Jeff Goldblum made some sort of
comment about Woody Allen and I saw that
people just like oh my god I can never
watch him pretend to fight a fake
dinosaur again I can't believe you just
say what you believe and own it and not
apologize and you're gonna hate this guy
because he has an opinion you're gonna
start treating him as though he did the
thing that you're accusing this other
guy you're doing that's where I kind of
but I saw enough pushback going like
guys guys you know this there's you know
there is pushback happening a lot more
yeah where it's just like all right
already all right also I think those
people really need to go talk to someone
because I think the people that get the
most offended have a lot jammed up from
their past I really do believe that I
think they're still upset about
something that happened to them or
things they went through and I feel like
if you really work on that a lot you're
you're you take it less personally when
someone says something like that
favorite thing is the the complaints I'm
hearing the most is from white women
that's I know I loved when we were
saying that on stage I was laughing it's
just [ __ ] like somehow they put
themselves at the front of oppressed
people white women in the United States
of America not saying they don't have
some [ __ ] that they got to go
through but Jesus Christ I mean yeah I
don't relate to that in certain ways at
all I also as a female may have gotten a
lot more work because I'm funny now I'm
serious like a lot of times they want a
woman on the show or need a woman so
I've gotten a lot of work because I've
I've played that the right way right of
just getting stronger and stronger and
being a woman that they know can deliver
what's your show what's the worst gig
early on that you did oh my god you're I
mean I don't know about here in New York
my first road gig I did bananas in
Poughkeepsie got in a [ __ ] hotel and
a holiday and it was my first paid road
gig and I was I was hosting and sharad
small was middling and I went up and I
was doing my thing and some guy stood up
and he's like you [ __ ] suck you fat
[ __ ] like just and I'm like dad no but
it seems like he was like screaming and
like in a point where it was like really
bad and I did not know how to make it
funny I was six months in so I was like
[ __ ] you and it was this horrible
screaming good instincts you went back I
went 11 I always do like I will like to
hack so I went [ __ ] crate and people
were freaking out like freaking out I
don't want to be your mother here but
how bad were you bombing that you made
that guy say that's you know I wasn't
I'm kidding I'm kidding
it was Larry like is anyone celebrating
I think it was so crazy he just hated me
so I was like you [ __ ] must beat your
wife you [ __ ] like I went oh that's
women what what'd your mother do to you
like I went because I have a therapist
background right my mom like I was you
get him did you get him back it was not
funny I got him back but it was not
funny
standing up and we were screaming I mean
it was really bad and then sherrod went
up and attacked the guy which I will
never forget that you did that he really
went crazy on the guy and I have to tell
you I was bedridden I was the first
shows that we first road show I ever did
did you have to do another one that
night or weekend oh no I do another one
that night - the next night it was no
there was a time that I would I would
not accept a gig if I had to get on the
87 North I just I just wouldn't do it
I know it's I I can't I was like I can't
get on there was something about as long
as I was still in the city it was sort
of magical and if I was on 87 a little
bit I wouldn't mind if I had to make a
left and start going out to Buffalo I
know but if I had to do that [ __ ] the
87 ad it's just always been straight
there's nothing to learn yeah it's the
same [ __ ] rest air infiltration camp
yeah it's bad I can't believe I just
didn't [ __ ] drive into a tree in
Canada one time I believe I haven't
either I can't believe the things I
dealt with but it's why I got good
because I've had a deal with horrible
I've worked like a dude I mean seriously
are you crazy and horrible some people
might but it's really truly like them I
know I mean going on the road by myself
and driving all over the country and
being in rental cars and not even going
into a rest up right at pee I'd pee in
the car cuz I was so afraid literally as
a woman at night he in the car how into
like I remember - a bottle once like a I
know that's not you guys could do that
well it was great we're kind of thing
were you is way more than it was a
Tupperware thing it wasn't like a soda
bomb that's what I was yeah
yeah a casserole but I was freaking it
was my grandmother's China no I was
really petrified to get out of the car
I understand makes sense but I know what
they did all that I really am this is
what I said to one guy one time when I
was talking about trying to understand
women and their fear when they walk
around it's like you have a watch as a
guy you when you watch one of those
behind the scenes prison things yeah and
you think how the [ __ ] would I go in
there and not get raped in it so now
it's like women kind of
to do that at different points during
the day yeah like at night stopping off
at a rest area getting to an elevator
with another guy by by yourself like
[ __ ] like that and then they were like
oh yeah I guess that I guess yeah I mean
when when I'm walking a lot of times I
think someone's walking behind me do you
feel like that if I ever feel that way I
think they're gonna Club me over the
head and take my wallet yeah I think
they're gonna rip my pants off and just
impregnate me like which is way worse
than using a purse yeah I don't speak
for you design yeah I don't know if the
purse snatchers your outfit what are you
going them is that a toss-up first of
all I don't wear a purse I wear a young
Beth what's the difference well like
I've never said can you get my purse I
mailed that way I don't I don't use the
word bag
yeah or a bag or something purse is very
however I dated a woman who wouldn't say
panties underwear get me underwear and
we could he's is so much hotter it is
underwear was just like I just never
liked BVDs and the [ __ ] 3-inch dick
coming out of her boobs yeah I just
didn't [ __ ] it was just one of those
people that was just sort of ante all of
that is such a heart that's a turn-off
to me well it never be with a woman like
that what's what's your type I go for
feminine women who are naturally pretty
usually dark hair ethnic looked I like
like darker Italian Jesus I know you
know what we're back in the day you and
I couldn't we couldn't Bend like wingmen
for each other now so we send me
pictures of like actually a comic sent
showed me a picture at the cellar the
other nights like you want to see a
picture of the girl and I thought it was
gonna be like a sexy picture of her just
like making a face oh no so guys gonna
be a close-up it was a close-up of her
[ __ ] and [ __ ] I'm like do I this
isn't this is too much I don't need to
see that I gotta admit I always thought
like that was one of my complaints about
the wage porn was always shot but there
was never enough time on her face
enjoying it it was it was like an
anatomy class it's like I get it his
dick is in her
then it's just like for the most part
because the lady's goods are internal
I'm really just looking at the
undercarriage of a guy it's like I felt
like I was watching like some
undercarriage I don't know why it's like
it was oddly like the Industrial
Revolution meets like you know was
missing was like a smokestack polluting
the local area so that was like my thing
when I would watch it it was just at
first you know then you know but that's
the danger of porn is you just watch it
for a while then you're like now this is
boring yeah I'm kind of build up I know
like you see their face one second the
next second it's covered in like black
tears and like it's like there's no arc
no I know that's what it is yeah it's
like and it ruins sex for a lot of
people I also do I also don't like those
porns where it just starts and they're
already [ __ ] it says oh I don't want
that animate what happened well I don't
like the ones either where they have the
camcorder on the ground like so tells me
she's like I'm sixteen like she's 34 oh
that's the world teen you don't want a
sceptic yes I and it's this whole
[ __ ] interview I didn't I don't want
that no I also don't want to go right to
it
Lauren TEDTalk no it's like the old
Calvin Klein ad my one I hate is when
there's a dude banging a chick and then
there's another dude talking [ __ ] with
the camera like go cuz he doesn't have
the courage to [ __ ] around Fillmore
doesn't have them doesn't have a non
dick on camera dick and it's just like
we shut the [ __ ] up
yeah you want that dick right you want
that like that's what he'll say to there
it's like it's like the robot him is
[ __ ] her and he's like bedridden or
something oh yeah I've never been I bet
here's the thing I've been trying to
like totally clean up my act like I quit
drinking he almost a year ago and now
I'm trying to cut back on cigars I kind
of pretty much have cut the porn
watching way down and it's been this
really challenging thing this is very
hard because then what it ends up it
becomes like this thing of like so I'm
just gonna take on every day I know you
have to feel everything
and deal with what the [ __ ] it's
breaketh mean I like it like I don't
know it's like to sit there you know
this all cuz it's emotional eating this
is [ __ ] watching porn this getting
smushed shopping yeah there's all of
that shambling work right working out I
mean you could eat it in anything yeah
so I'm sitting there going like you know
so yeah you can literally spend a
lifetime hiding from whatever the [ __ ]
it is that you could maybe then try it
we say there's four garbage cans in
three lids like there's always one thing
that's brewing for me [ __ ] look at
like if I'm not drinking or doing drugs
I'm not smoking cigarettes I'm not
eating I'm not gambling like I'm
flirting more like it's just he's like
always something that I have to look at
don't you feel like it's it's just you
just need you once you find out what a
rush is you kind of like you've like
it's almost hard to go like 24 48 hours
without feeling some sort of heightened
thing and when I was sitting there like
look thinking about my life being like I
didn't really start going out hanging
out my buddies my beer drinking buddies
you know back in the day in high school
I was like 17 so I spent a decade and a
half
like straightedge you know just cuz yeah
is why probably you started doing
wanting to partner oh no no no but I
mean like I was able to handle that then
and it wasn't a problem at all but once
I found out like what a release going
out and you know and drinking like it
that when I started full Budweiser's
that's all it took I remember like
during like midweek I would start to
feel like God man I'm getting [ __ ]
hammered this weekend I can't [ __ ]
like I was going out to get shit-faced
and I just think that there's a thing
that once you do that because I mean
there's a couple comics I know that I've
never drank never did drugs you know and
they're like my age but that's
impressive
yeah but then you know something then
they tend to be like women eyes errs but
I don't think that's the worst thing as
long as it practicing safe sex and then
I [ __ ] hurt anybody I don't think
going out and banging a bunch of [ __ ]
women is necessarily I don't either I
mean nuts
the worst thing I I think if you're not
hurting anyone it's fine
and you're being careful but they should
teach you how to do that yeah how did
not hurt somebody because they don't
because I I've I have a lot like I heard
a lot of people come just be out of
being an idiot and I just wish that they
like they taught you I know like to
think to respect the opposite sex or
whatever the [ __ ] you're into and then
how not to hurt them so you could just
be like this [ __ ] Zen dude just walk
around being like I'm not ready to be in
a relationship but I but I you know I am
looking to having fun most men don't
know they really aren't taught that they
just do what they think is the right
thing and they don't they don't even
mean they don't even know it's not okay
until later on then another thing too is
like when you finally get laid you're
like holy [ __ ] it's finally happening
it's like when you're first trying to be
a comedian you [ __ ] every funny thing
that you said you start getting into
these [ __ ] relationships where
there's really nothing there but you
don't have the confidence that another
woman is actually gonna want to have sex
with you so in the early on you just
keep those for me you kept getting into
these relationships before you finally
just like what the [ __ ] am i doing
I don't want to be in this and I'm
hurting people so then you just sort of
stopped yeah being in relationships yeah
you did yeah and then you met your wife
is that what yeah that's usually how it
works yeah then I was just like all
right [ __ ] this and then I met when I
met Nia I was actually a little upset
when I was just like oh [ __ ] you mean
now I'm like I'm I like this person Oh
got it because I was kind of thinking
like yeah I was enjoying like what I
found was I know Ted Alexandro has a
grad the greatest joke about that where
it sucks at night but for the rest of
the day it was awesome like waking up I
think I've heard him say yeah I forget
how he worded it perfectly yeah as
always but I just remember waking up not
being in a [ __ ] relationship was the
great it's just like drinking
yeah not drinking sucks at night waking
up stone [ __ ] sober like not hungover
yeah eight hours of great sleep you like
I feel like I could run through a
[ __ ] brick wall right now
and I remember what I would during that
time when I was just like [ __ ] this I'm
not good at relationships I'm not doing
this anymore
waking up and not having that person
next to me thinking like oh god is this
the right thing what am i doing yeah
like yeah just not having that and just
not hurting anybody
you know and being able to be like I'm
not in a relationship and just [ __ ]
being cool with that I've done that to
myself a lot where I'm like I'm just not
good in a relationship like it's hard
you don't want to hurt someone you want
to make sure you're getting and like
it's like so much work yeah it really is
oh yeah I love your relationship and how
you are in your relationship because
it's rare for cook for comedians at our
age it's like what we were just saying
I'm done thank God I met oh geez because
that was my big fear I'm gonna be that
50 year old [ __ ] guy but there's so
many that I know and then they kill and
then they stand out in front of the club
Hey ladies
look at her they're desperate for that
love and connection and they want kids
and they want a wife and oh it's so soon
die in your hair it's just it's a bad it
just becomes like a bad like it's a bad
[ __ ] it's a bad look so I don't know
so anyways I really I got to tell you
something I really am excited for this
thing to come out and for people to see
what a great comic you are in those 20
years that you put in after peeing into
[ __ ] Tupperware into of Oz into Avaaz
elegant in the beginning yeah why always
was you know came from money no but I'm
hoping like it's it's done you know it
did great things for virzi like Rosie's
now about the headlining Ian Edwards to
starting a headline and all that type of
stuff and I'm just hoping like all you
guys so already started from people
hearing about it I things are on a roll
I mean like I you know I'm doing the
Tonight Show soon and I didn't know that
yeah I am yeah I'm like there's a lot
going on well the minute people heard
about it they were so excited it's also
a great story it's like a lot of people
will pick the 25 year old or 30 year old
hot girl who's like really I
Roenick and says really smart thing you
know it's it's a great story they all
seem to be just talking about their
vaginas they are dick and it's [ __ ]
hilarious
oh yeah I really feel like a lot of
female comics are the new dick joke
comics I remember standing waiting to go
into comedy store and there was this
female comic on stage and the [ __ ] she
was talking about I just looked at this
other guy we just started laughing and
it took me back to when I first started
headlining in the 90s and there would be
you know one of those 80s headliners who
was now middling and and they went once
they went into this section you knew
that this was the this was they were
gonna be wrapping it up and there was
there was that brought the proctologists
finger in your ass bit yeah I know
that's a big one that is a big one that
I said and any one and then they would
end screaming the whole place going nuts
yeah and they would be on eleven and
then I would go first few times I went
up there and I made the mistake of
starting my act at eleven just coming up
[Applause]
yeah and I and I would yeah and then
also giving eleven energy to [ __ ] that
didn't even deserve a six right and I
would be eight minutes into my set and I
would literally be like [ __ ] out of
breath and I forget who the [ __ ] finally
told me how to handle [ __ ] like he was
the one who I think might have been like
Jeff Ross or somebody told me yeah cuz I
used to watch Jeff follow these really
high-energy guys so I learned that like
you have to start way beneath their
thing and then you know it takes about
five minutes and then build back up
again but like I remember some of the
[ __ ] [ __ ] I had to go on and I know
it's unbelievable
through louis c.k told me a story one
time he had to go on this guy's closing
bit was it was he played the national
anthem with fart noises and it was an
actual orchestra playing it and then he
was like farting they like the fart
nerds and the guy was making the faces
and he said it was like oh must have
been it was bedlam
yeah bedlam and he had the [ __ ] go on
there and like and follow that I got to
get him on here and have [ __ ] tell
this story I have to tell well he was
very complimentary to me he saw me like
six months ago and said you're really
one of the best comics theory I mean it
was really sweet what he said to me
there you go yeah I don't mean there are
a lot of female comics who don't just
talk about that and they're [ __ ]
killer but I just was in LA and it was
really common there it was my thing I'm
not trying to [ __ ] on like no I'm just
sure there are the good ones don't
that's my love like it's like yeah I get
it yeah I mean if you put things in
there it's it's easier I'm gonna be
honest when I go up and do that kind of
stuff it gets big lit it's easy to talk
about you know why that's why I never
really did sex jokes yeah because I
always cuz the the level of like
laughing that people would do and then
then like nothing in my act could follow
that you can't start with section I I
found that you couldn't do that so you
my own thing was the only thing I
anytime if I would do something like
that I was also like my Catholic
upbringing I was a bit of a [ __ ]
prude I think but I always loved the
comics some of my favorite comics did
kind of do stuff like that but like as
long as there was like like because I
think some people get branded dirty who
aren't dirty I do too like I remember
early on in the in the Boston scene when
Joe Rogan came up and it was you know
there was all of these [ __ ] guys who
he blew off the stage really is what it
was and then he had left town so then
they were talking all this disco he was
just you know you know filthy blah blah
blah yeah that's what I do right and
then I remember I saw Joe at the kowloon
and I'm like this guy is that this guy's
brilliant like his his yeah tigers
[ __ ] bit now if you want to just be
like just throw everything into a bin
okay it that is a sex joke but the
performance yeah the point of view right
a sound effect of the [ __ ] tiger I
mean my that was like a face-melting bit
for me to watch and then even like his
throwaway stuff yeah he said he had this
joke I feel like I hate doing
jokes but this was so [ __ ] this is
like 20 years ago I did this yeah he did
this joke he said you ever see uh you
ever you ever have a woman give you a
[ __ ]
he goes it's like brushing your teeth
with your left hand and that's like one
of those things like okay technically
that is a dick joke but that is a
generally n't ya [ __ ] joke and where
I was in my life right then was like I
that was being that was becoming that
those who are experiences that I had and
that was the [ __ ] that was the worst it
was almost it was almost worse than not
having sex at all yeah it was that bad
and he put it so perfectly in so quickly
like the way a Steven Wright could but
it was like a it had to do with sex so
these guys I see all that you know I
mean I think it's dirty just to be dirty
then it's not funny right dirty stuff I
don't even kill a soldier unless if
you're being dirty just to be dirty just
to annoy the shot that's my favorite
comment and that is [ __ ] we're trying to
really offend people and you're doing it
for that reason I'll die laughing I saw
Bob zmuda do the the Andy Kaufman
character there what the [ __ ] a guy's
name I always forget the character's
name it's one of my favorite um Tony
wait no oh I know what you're talking
about I know my brains Friday so is mine
so he went up there and he was doing
this [ __ ] bit and he was gonna sing a
song with the band and he was in the
most the crowd was so young they didn't
know who the character was and he was
just annoying the [ __ ] out of everybody
and then he goes it's just this song is
dedicated to the American Indians and
then he just starts naming tribes he
goes to sue the Kuo rapaho Blackfeet I
can't breathe a minute later Apache yeah
he just kept yeah [ __ ] going I was
crying I know I've done that with
Gilbert Godfried where I literally have
almost thrown up from laughing where
I've opened for him years ago and he
would just torture people at Caroline's
like half the crowd would walk out he
would literally it
he literally played with the microphone
once for like 10 minutes do you know how
long that is like he would not stop
trying to adjust it and he wouldn't say
anything and people were like what the
[ __ ] going on like and then half the
crowd was screaming laughing because
they they understood him but that kind
of [ __ ] makes me laugh harder than
anything I mean can you pick a harder
Road now doing that like I've been a
crowd-pleasing jackass since the [ __ ] me
yeah I can't believe like I used to
watch Patrice [ __ ] walk rooms and
like I don't think I've ever seen more
joy on his face yes because you realize
even when you they like you it doesn't
mean anything and when they don't like
you like nothing means I think it was
like a power in that way like yeah how
much you try to act like you don't give
a [ __ ] when you would like walk a room
but my thing is I always used to think
if you well if somebody left and the fun
was over the key was make them want to
leave but just enough that they didn't
so then they had to keep listening to
you yeah they look tortured I like when
people are afraid to leave when I'm
going off on it yeah that's the best
what do you have for people who want to
see you live before your special drops
here do you got anything coming up the
next month
yep they go to Jessica Carson calm ki
RSO n it has my whole schedule met the
stress factory in Bridgeport
Thanksgiving weekend and then in New
Jersey whereas where I'm from so that's
awesome and yeah I have a ton of stuff
coming up if they just go on my schedule
it's all listed there all right
beautiful
well I'm such a huge fan and I'm so
happy that we got to get in business
together and I'm my podcast to your
company oh you all know that yeah just a
pretty face oh yeah my podcast is
relatively sane and I just moved it to
all things comedy alright well next time
cuz I got a quick run here in New York
next time you come out to LA bring you a
little I'll just come by ATC
I will and will not going out yes all
right Jessica Carson December 6th Comedy
Central talking to myself one of the
best out there that you need to know
about alright thank you for listening go
[ __ ] yourselves and I'll check in on you
on Thursday